[Musique]
mais qu'est-ce qui a les marcheurs
monsieur jumelles monsieur jumelles
voilà je pense que votre histoire à
lédar je mentais couler exprimé 307
majorité 154 pour 214 contre 93 et après
ces débats particulièrement ajouté
depuis lundi un jt depuis lundi soir les
députés ont donc voté la transformation
du pass sanitaire repasse vaccinale cela
veut dire que désormais le vaccin
devient obligatoire pour les plus de 12
ans pour les activités de loisirs les
restaurants et les transports régionaux
il faut désormais que ce texte passe au
sénat donc il vient d'être voté vous
venez de le dire ce matin et c'est
heureux permettez moi quand même demain
félicité c'est une bonne chose
moi j'aimerais 2000 en mer d'autres gens
oui oui j'aimerais bien qu'ils emmerdent
les caïds les trafiquants de drogue les
types qui ont brûlé encore les voitures
comme d'habitude à la saint sylvestre
cafetiers et les restaurateurs
ils pourront vérifier les identités en
cas de suspicion de faux-pas sanitaires
sur les la possible en espérant qu'ils
vont emmerder les français quoi si j'ai
bien compris eux les patrons de bars qui
vont emmerder les français
si nous sommes tous citoyens personne
emmerdera personne fait dans quel monde
allons-nous vivre à la fin tout le monde
va contrôler tout le monde
j'arrête une société totalitaire on est
en train de basculer dans un système de
discrimination
ou
notre liberté qui normalement est au
dessus tout va être conditionné à un
comportement de santé demain les fumeurs
après demain les opposants la retraite
il a réussi emmanuel macron à vous
imposer sont mes impôts impôts et
attendez attendez imposer le paradigme
quotidien comme le sujet qui écrase
toujours à cambrai vous avez raison il a
réussi là pendant une semaine ça ne
durera pas autant que les impôts comme
dirait mon père il faut ressortir le
kärcher il a été remisé à la cave par
françois hollande emmanuel macron depuis
dix ans aujourd'hui il est temps de
nettoyer les quartiers et il faut
traquer les caïds les voyous valérie
pécresse fait ainsi référence à un
ancien ministre de l'intérieur lorsqu'il
s'agit de parler sécurité c'était en
novembre 2005 lors des émeutes de
banlieue jean ferrat valérie qu'il
faudrait qu'elle se renouvelle un petit
peu récupéré comme ça des anciennes
phrase sans faire de proposition
c'est un peu petit parce que je voulais
vous dire tout ça la couleur la police
d'écriture le logo tout y est sauf que
ces sachets saisis par la gendarmerie du
vaucluse sont siglés haribo le fameux
slogan a même été habilement remplacé on
peut y lire haribo c'est beau la vie il
ya de la weed et du tai chi mais si ceci
dit toi le coût du karcher cvo trier
non c'est l'idée de valérie pécresse
était donnée g mais c'est pas mon idée
je revendique pas toutes les idées
fausses et pas votre idée mais c'est ma
victoire j'imagine madame pécresse
refait le cirque de nicolas sarkozy de
jacques chirac c'est la même chose des
mots des mots des mots et il n'y aura
pas de résultat impossible bientôt dans
certains pays d'y échapper sous peine
d'amendé en italie obligation vaccinale
pour les plus de 50 ans à partir du 15
février brigitte bardot elle assume
totalement qu'elle le fait de ne pas
être vaccinés c'est ce qu'elle dit dans
le bas dans le magazine gala ah non je
suis allergique à tous les produits
chimiques même si vous refusez les
produits chimiques si vous attrapez le
vide c'est ça la ccl finalement
l'honneur de la france c'est que vous
serez soignés et que vous serez présent
en charge même si vous avez refusé de
vous faire vacciner même quand j'ai
voyagé en afrique j'ai refusé de le
faire contre la fièvre jaune mon médecin
de l'époque m'avait rédigé un faux
certificat aps la vaccination est en
train de devenir une religion et il sait
des comportements religieux qu'on voit
avec des gens qui sont devenus des
missionnaires de la vaccination la bonne
nouvelle c'est qu'on est à 95 jour d'en
finir avec ce virus d'une artiste qui
appelle macro 10 mhz